i heard our boy tim kenny got some [ __ ]
this weekend you hear about this no
a bunch of uh former military were like
saying like you know going hard in the
paint on tim but it sounds like tim was
trying to help and he gathered a bus of
like two buses of people who were uh
stranded out there and then he was
trying to get them through to through
the airport but it what it did it caused
a four-hour delay at least to get
everybody through so some families
didn't get through so some people were
so pissed
but it sounds like he was trying to help
yeah it's a cluster [ __ ] and the cluster
[ __ ] is going to make a lot of people
really angry
look at him i look man the guy went
there so [ __ ] off he's doing the best he
can look how many people he saved dude
they said he drove two bus filled with
people trying to get out
but it just doesn't work like they gotta
they go through the process and make
sure they're you know they're not
terrorists coming here and yeah
finding them is a big problem getting
them on is a big problem
right when i get on the ground we're
doing a uh reconnaissance of a new rat
line a spot that we're planning on every
trying to smuggle some more people
through and around the car looking on
top of the building there's taliban
listing post opposition posts with
trained observers that were looking to
the airfield to try and identify where
all of the american forces were that a
sniper rifle up there obviously their
job was to be prepared to deal death
against american forces and if afghans
are trying to get out
uh
saying the operation had to be shifted a
few hundred meters behind another
building so those guys wouldn't shoot at
us can you say a variety of people
include american citizens christians
orphans pilots teachers were rescued
during the missions i'm sorry people are
upset at our guy tim kennedy
he's captain america man yeah
i think the issue was by him doing that
like going rogue this i don't know the
exact situation but from what i hear
from these haters is him going rogue it
caused them to like have to focus on his
people but then other families didn't
get out right but it sounds like he got
a bunch of people out
so how can be mad at the guy
i don't know anything anything tim does
i'm going to be a fan of so tim can do
no wrong yeah for me anyway i mean i i
just know that he went there
sounds like on his own dime like i mean
he went to afghanistan to go help people
talk about putting your money where your
mouth is the guy's got kids
oh yeah he's
he he
he he walks
the talk and
i always admire people like that